have you ever sat down to look over your
checking account and find out there's a
mistake and it's not just a mistake but
you're going to be an overdraft and
you're going to bounce checks your
electric bills going to be drafted and
it's going to bounce or you don't have
the money now to pay your car payment
because you goofed on that I remember my
heart racing and a little sweat on the
upper lip a little sweat in the palms of
my hands and how scared I would be
because I couldn't pay something and I
was out of control and I was behind I
remember that feeling plus I felt stupid
I would felt ashamed and then I added
zeros to it because I got into a bunch
of real estate debt millions of dollars
worth and and the bank called our notes
and then everything was out of control
and I went from merely being ashamed and
merely being scared - completely
terrified I was so stinkin scared I
couldn't breathe my wife you know she
used to think before that that I was
smart but here I was we were losing
everything they cut our water off and
I'm pretty handy so I went out there and
turned it back on then they came and
took the meter out that's not funny
it's not funny at all it wasn't funny we
didn't have any water I had little kids
in the house
it was awful I had to go sell stuff and
I you know I figured out some way to
sell some stuff and got went and paid
the bill and they put the meter back in
because I was stealing waters what
amounted to that scared I was that
stupid I was that broke never been there
you ever gone the driveway and wondered
if the car was going to be there
you're afraid he's going to be picked up
it were parked your car in the garage so
they couldn't repo it because you knew
they were after it you ever had such a
fight with your spouse because they lied
to you about spending that you thought
your marriage was over have you ever
looked at your kids and wondered if they
were actually going to go to school be
able to go to college because you're so
freakin irresponsible you don't know
where your money's going and you have
this sense of shame like I'm a bad
parent have you ever bought something
and you woke up the next morning and you
felt like I must be 4 years old I
completely impulse that and it's a major
purchase and now we've got more payments
and we're so stupid now we got more
payments ever walked into
or Costco and thought the guy checking
at the door was checking to make sure
you spent $200 so you leave with nine
gallons of peanut butter because you
just know you it's a deal
you ever signed paperwork to borrow
money and not even read it don't even
know what you got into only to find out
later that they screwed you
you got prepayment penalties and a
higher interest rate than you were
promised the guy on the other side of
the table lied but you didn't read the
check and so it's your fault you ever
done that I have I've done all those
things then every bit of that most
people do by the way you ever fill up
all your credit cards and since you need
to keep living you go by you go fill out
applications for more new credit cards
and then you're mad because they turn
you down for the ability to go further
into debt because you're already screwed
you ever done that I have I mean yeah at
some point I get it in other words I've
been there done that I've got the
t-shirt Sharon and I have yelled at each
other over NSF fees we have yelled at
each other over her spending too much of
the grocery store when she wasn't we had
those money fights
really and we're like hillbillies so we
know how to fight it ain't pretty you
know it's a lot of years ago about 30
years ago when all that was happening
you know when I sitting here talking
about it it feels like it just happened
20 minutes ago I can still feel the
shame I can still feel the guilt I can
still feel the lack of confidence
creeping up in the back of my throat
causing a knot tightness if you
to any of that let me tell you this it
doesn't have to be and then that to be
that way you work too hard to be this
broke but you're going to start making
adult decisions to the child decisions
you don't have to live this way you can
you can live on a plan you can get in
control you can get the stupid car paid
off or sell it you can be on a plan that
your spouse and you are in agreement and
there's unity and there's communication
in your marriage you can start looking
at your kids and go hey I got your back
kiddo I got your dadgum College Fund
started I'm on baby step five because I
busted through baby step two we sold
everything we're getting out of debt
we're getting our dadgum life back we're
not living like this I'm sick and tired
of being sick and tired I'm gonna change
you can decide that here's what's funny
it's just like that you just decide I'm
not living from stupidity to stupidity
from guilt to guilt from shame to shame
from dumb decision to dumb decision
anymore I stopped it today I'm done I'm
done
I'm not living like this anymore you can
make that decision right now ready set
go
get your stupid credit cards out and cut
them up right now right now if you keep
doing stupid don't scratch your head and
wonder why you're freaking broke if you
keep being immature and four act like
you're four years old don't scratch your
head and wonder why you're broke but you
can stop it I did you can stop it you
can decide to stop it right now you can
jump online and find a Financial Peace
University class and get your butt in
one there's people there that have made
mistakes there's people there that will
love you in spite of your fact you've
been stupid cuz I've been stupid and I'm
the guy wrote the course so shut up you
can get in there and people will love
you anyway because they've been stupid
too and we're going to stop it together
this is a stop stupid movement that's
what this is this is a grow up and be an
adult movement that's what this is
and we'll help you well show you how am
I going it's a proven plan it's step by
step by step you do exactly what I teach
you will win this stuff works 10 million
people really can't be that wrong this
is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show you can do
this you know that really is a message
whether you've got two hundred seventy
thousand dollars in student loan debt or
twenty seven thousand well you've got a
fifty thousand dollar income on a five
hundred thousand dollar income